[Music]
[Music]
i'm in favor as a long run goal
not something achieved tomorrow but
something to keep our eye on
of trying to move to a condition where
we eradicate race from social judgment
[Music]
race is here and what we do with it is
completely up to us
i am of the belief that what we will not
do
is eliminate it
[Music]
you're either part of the journey for
change
or you're part of a system that wants to
keep the status quo
hello we want to see the end of
discrimination
on the grounds of race to this end in
2018
france unanimously voted to remove the
word race from its constitution
endorsing the view that race should play
no part in any decision or action
yet at the same time many want to assert
their right to be proud of their
heritage
and see race as a defining part of their
identity
should we be seeking to eradicate race
from social judgments
and as a result must we give up
attachment to being part of any
particular racial group
or does ignoring race cover up historic
injustices
and disregard inherent differences in
identity
well it's a fascinating and extremely
timely debate
and i'm very glad to say that we've got
three outstanding speakers to join us
this evening first we have professor
glenn lowry
uh he is the merton p staltz professor
at brown university in the united states
but he was also the first
african-american tenured professor
of economics in the history of harvard
university back in 1982.
glenn's vehement criticism of
affirmative action
led to him becoming extremely well known
and highly regarded
on the intellectual right from the 1980s
onward
then we have george mapanga who's better
known to many as george the poet
an award-winning podcaster spoken word
artist and cultural critic
george first gained prominence as part
of a new generation of spoken word
artists challenging the traditionalism
of poetry recital
and you can hear his podcast called have
you heard george's podcast
on bbc sounds and dawn butler
is labour mp for brent central and she
served as
shadow women and equality secretary and
shadow minister
for diverse communities now
in the traditional if there is such a
thing traditional how light gets in way
we're going to start by asking each of
our speakers to give us up to three
minutes in which they address a
particular question
and the question to start us off with is
should we be seeking to eradicate
race from social judgments and i wonder
if we could start with you glenn lowry
over to you for three minutes
very well then uh let me be provocative
yes as my answer to that question
uh we should be seeking to eradicate
race from social judgments
now i don't say that this will happen
immediately i don't say that we should
pretend that race doesn't exist
or that we should ignore the history of
racial oppression slavery discrimination
and so on
but what should we be seeking to do as a
society over the long run
we should be seeking to transcend racial
categorization
these are ways of looking at ourselves
which we inherit from the past
we need not be imprisoned by them this
is a conception of the person which at
some level
is superficial it defines us in terms of
the color of our skin the texture of our
hair the shape of bones in our face
that's not who we are
that's our packaging now
i acknowledge that as a practical matter
given the conditions on the ground in
many countries in the world
the legacies of racial oppression
require redress
effective redress cannot be accomplished
without some kind of cognizance of
racial identity
but that's the legacy of the past
we should be attempting to transcend it
if we believe in racial justice if we
genuinely believe in racial equality
the long run solution to this problem is
to subvert
these categories altogether to be
miscegenation uh mongers to marry across
racial lines to integrate our
communities to assimilate our values one
to another across the racial divide
i think history gives us plenty of
reason to expect that the
society built on the foundation of
trans-racial humanism
is a more just and equal society than
the many tribal societies that we see
around the world today where conflict
inequality
and enmity fester so i'm in favor as a
long-run goal
not something achieved tomorrow but
something to keep our eye on
of trying to move to a condition where
we eradicate race from social judgments
glenn larry thank you very much indeed
for that very succinct uh and
provocative opening statement
and we will turn immediately for the
next statement to
george george the purge please go ahead
i don't think we should be seeking to
eradicate race from our
social judgments the difference is
between
us on a physical level are superficial
on a social level they've been exploited
to justify
uh practices and social orders which
are imbalanced and unfortunately that
has shaped our present
race is here and what we do with it is
completely up to us
i am of the belief that what we will not
do
is eliminate it we will not erase it
from the social memory
and we will not get any better at
denying the reality
of racism
we can only look to begin explaining
how racism persists and
we can seek to undermine the mechanisms
of racism
i envision a society in which we are all
so well versed in our history
in the bits of our history that we can
claw back in the
parts of our current existence that we
can verify
person to person i look forward to a
society
in which our young people are versed on
inequality
our young people learn in school the mec
the mechanics of power
and the persistence of social injustice
i anticipate this future and i see it as
essential
in providing an equal footing in which
learners can leave the education process
enter the workforce build healthy happy
functional lives productive lives in
which they feel that the
consequence of their work reflects the
essence of who they
are and the only way that i believe the
society can be reached
is by digging into our inequalities
digging into the archives and
understanding
how the differences between us
geographic
superficial physical
situational and otherwise have been
manipulated
have been exploited to leave us living
in conditions today
in which racial inequality pervades
every element
of our existence we should get better at
talking about this
we should we should have formalized
processes we should have institutions
that reflect this understanding and we
should be brave
in passing the baton onto the generation
following us
giving them the faith to believe that
they can lead us to a better tomorrow
but we will not do that by pretending
race
does not exist thank you very much uh
indeed uh george and again
extremely concise extremely potent and
provocative in the right sort of
way dawn could i turn to you for our
third
opening statement thank you rana and
thank you to both glenn and george
for those opening statements and
um i agree with george
um it would be utopia if
uh race was not a part of
um the remarks the actions
in society but the fact is this race is
a social
uh construct but racism is very much
real and tangible and dangerous
the fact of the matter is that racism
exists
discrimination exists and biases exist
if we do not acknowledge it or measure
it we cannot take
action on it and to ignore race is to
ignore
uh the stories and journeys of
each and every african caribbean asian
minority ethnic people
and communities and we have to accept
and acknowledge
the journeys biases has consequences
and if we do not recognize that we
cannot measure it and we cannot mitigate
against it and that is why we're going
on this journey at the moment it's
very difficult at the moment for some
it's a very uncomfortable conversation
for some
it's a very confronting and challenging
conversation for some
but it's a necessary conversation what
surprises me that people are surprised
they're surprised at the lived
experiences of people of color
and i often wonder why are they
surprised it's because
they live in a different world in a
different bubble where
they are not subjected to everyday
lived racism just because of the color
of one's skin
so i would say for those who try their
best to pretend that they don't see
color they will often then fail to see
the injustices
that comes with being a person of color
and if we're going to move beyond that
we have to just talk frankly about it
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas